[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show there were
primaries last night although with so
much going on they did not necessarily
get the headlines that some might have
imagined
one of the big and important ones was
the republican gubernatorial primary in
wisconsin where
mickles defeated cleefish and i have to
tell you pat that is not a race that i
followed closely was it a maga versus
non-maga sort of situation it was so
trump pulled off the victory here he
endorsed mikkels the establishment
republicans they wanted kleefisch who is
the i believe former lieutenant governor
of the state and so people like mike
pence endorsed her and so it was another
showdown between the manga types and the
non-mega types and when you think about
the situations where trump and pence
have
endorsed different candidates in a race
it looks like trump is now two and one
against pence because trump got the win
here and also with the kerry lake race
in arizona right but pence pulled out a
victory in georgia uh with david perdue
getting defeated there by brian kemp so
i want to see if more of these types of
head-to-head matches continue but as far
as it goes for now trump is up two to
one against yep and of course uh what
happens in november will have the most
electoral importance in the sense of
does a democrat or a republican actually
remain because slash become governor
uh in wisconsin and we will that's one
we're going to be following very closely
from a gubernatorial standpoint now also
interesting in vermont becca balance
will become the first woman to represent
the state in congress she won the
democratic primary and the winner of the
democratic primary there is essentially
a shoo-in to win in november as well so
that's interesting in connecticut
governor ned lamont and democratic
senator richard blumenthal
um
both got their republican challengers
uh and both are expected to defeat those
republican challengers in november which
i don't think will come as a shock to
too many people and then in minnesota
congresswoman ilhan omar
did win her democratic primary she seems
to be increasingly having a problem in
her district where her margin of victory
has shrunk
there's been significant shrinkage over
time where she only won by two percent
last night whereas in the past she has
won her primary but by as much as 20
so that's a pretty dramatic shift for
ilhan omar
to be honest i didn't even know about
that it makes sense because you know her
state was having an election so you'd
think that okay she's going to be in a
contested primary right two percent
you'd think that that would be more of a
news event going into it knowing that
there was a significant chance of her
being ousted from office right it's good
news that she was able to fight that off
at least yeah she should be worried
about 24. i think that's that's uh
that's clear with this diminishing
margin each time but i i don't know that
much about her district but i assume the
winner of the dem primary wins the
district right i don't know maybe i
should the minneapolis area so she'll be
fine and then um
also in vermont there's the
gubernatorial primary for the democrats
brenda siegel won that one but she's
going to go up against republican
governor phil scott and vermont is one
of these new england states where they
just love to vote in republican
governors even though they're very
progressive states and phil scott is
perhaps the most popular governor in the
entire country he's like a 60 approval
rating so siegel even though she's a
democrat she probably isn't going to win
that race we also have that issue in
massachusetts where we have charlie
baker very popular republican and he won
re-election when he ran
easily against a democrat it's just one
of those things that new england likes
to do likes to
vote in republican governors and just a
quick note on the fifth congressional
district in minnesota ilhan omar's
district i just looked
1963 was the last time that a republican
represented that district that was
walter judd whose 20-year tenure ended
in 1963 and since then it's been
democrats all the way down
two of them
three of them actually to retirement
keith ellison retired but it's sort of
like it
you know he retired to run for attorney
general and it's kind of a
retirement has a different meaning when
you're as young as he was but in any
case they all went to retirement and we
will see if ilhan omar does the same
thing
u.s lawmakers are looking to crack down
on airlines over canceled flights
the proposal from two house democrats is
to make it illegal for airlines to offer
flights if they know they don't have the
staff
or to cancel flights close to scheduled
departures because of an issue that's
foreseeable now obviously if there is
a delayed inbound flight
so the the the crew that's coming in
is two hours late and this puts them
into where they have to have a mandated
rest period
that is beyond a foreseeable event
unless it is a very particular situation
where they knew that they were going to
end up being late but let's assume it's
because of weather a mechanical issue
nobody's talking about that but these
airlines have very sophisticated systems
for putting together these crew
schedules and some of these staffing
issues right now are known to be
foreseeable in the sense of the schedule
might be the schedule the airline has
always had but if they know they're
eight percent down on staff it becomes
predictable that some of these flights
are are highly likely to be cancelled
lawmakers want to punish airlines for
doing that and i have to tell you pat
i'm not for over-regulation i do think
something needs to be done because
everyone i know is have has been in
horrible flight situations in many cases
for what seemed like foreseeable issues
lately oh totally yeah the last few
months have been terrible with cancelled
flights and whenever i have a vacation
coming up or a trip somewhere i'm always
just like oh there's a good chance or at
least a decent chance yeah i may have to
find another flight so that's annoying
and stressful uh and you have to wonder
like is this the type of thing that's
getting the attention of people in
congress because they have to fly around
the country all the time like with so
many issues it seems like you can't get
a hold of your congress person or
senator to complain about it and they
drag their feet and don't do much of
anything but i'm sure they've had to
deal with the cancellations and the bs
responses from the airlines so
with with this issue they're quick to
act so that's good at least yeah and
again it's not about you know i'm not
looking for people to lose their jobs
i'm not it's just let's make it function
better and
just in the last month i had
my brother's flight uh
from montreal to la
just cancelled uh two hours before no
explanation given just cancelled um then
was rerouted through dallas and montreal
to dallas cancelled uh then got on the
next montreal to dallas left the gate
sat on the tarmac for two hours back to
the gate cancelled eventually got on
montreal to los angeles insane friends
recently um just i mean listen the
anecdotes don't matter but almost
everybody is saying i had a major issue
with a domestic flight or like a mexico
us or canada u.s type flight on an
american airline this sounds to me like
cancel culture run amok
taking on a different meaning of cancel
culture oh it's set up yeah once we deal
with this then we have to get to the
bumping issue as well where they
overbook flights deliberately knowing
that some people will have to cancel
their own reservations and then
sometimes you have instances where
there's an auction to see who's willing
to get off the flight have you ever
experienced one of those because i
haven't seen that yet where they're like
haggling okay we'll give you a hundred
bucks to get off the flight 200 bucks
500 i have not seen that on the plane
but i have seen in the gate area that
they start saying we need eight people
to volunteer to get on the next one
we're offering x amount and i've never
seen it get crazy i know that sometimes
people will say well they offered a
hundred bucks and then it ended up being
2 000 because they needed to get people
off i've never seen that even though
i've heard about it happening but i've
seen like hey we'll give you 250 bucks
if you get on the first flight tomorrow
morning and put you up in a free hotel
and give you a hundred dollars in a food
voucher and they got enough volunteers
where that's as far as it went
yeah because i'm thinking like a hundred
dollars for most people given if they
have plans right have reservations ahead
of time all the hassle probably not
going to be worth it correct but if
you're talking 250 plus a hundred dollar
food voucher and a free stay at a hotel
all of a sudden i'm interested that's
considering it now if you get up to two
thousand you've been yeah i'm gonna be
taking that paddle order room service
watch some uh you know jr tolkien movies
or whatever and you know turn it into a
real party all right so anyway let's see
what happens this is the proposal from
jan schakowsky and david cicilline both
members of congress who i've met
interestingly enough jan schakowsky's
actually been on the show and we will
follow it most americans support a
national popular vote to decide who
becomes president of the united states
think of how crazy that is most
americans 63 percent say
the candidate who gets the most votes
nationally should become the president
isn't that an insane point of view pat
yeah if only we could just have a
national vote to decide how we pick
presidents correct then we'd be able to
institute the national popular vote
right away instead we have to come up
with these other sorts of systems like
thinking about constitutional amendment
a constitutional convention or what
seems to be more likely the national
interstate compact
to try to get about the popular vote
effectively doing away with the
electoral college that's right and we'll
mention that in a moment but the bottom
line is as follows
republicans
benefit from the electoral college as it
exists today now i know that trump and
others have said
if the if the president was selected by
a national popular vote
we would have run the race differently
so you can't just say
oh this race would have been won by
someone else because the entire campaign
would have been different fine that's
that may be the case as it stands
multiple republicans have become
president while losing the popular vote
that includes george w bush in the year
2000 who lost the popular vote
nationally to al gore
it was about what half a million votes
or so pat at the time i believe yeah
about half a million votes and then in
2016 donald trump became the president
despite losing the popular vote by it
was about 2.8 or so million votes
something like that that's right yep now
uh those are two examples where the
winner would have been a democrat did we
have a popular vote 2020 is also an
interesting example because 2020 ended
up heavily contested on the basis of a
handful of states
even though joe biden won the popular
vote by 8 million votes so again the
entire voter fraud audits all this stuff
that was only even an issue because of
the electoral college because we're just
a popular vote listen eight million
votes were fraudulent in the wrong
direction now they probably would have
claimed it pat but it would would have
gotten even less attention and so i'm in
favor of this
two-thirds of americans are in favor of
this
and like many things americans want
we're probably not going to get it
anytime soon definitely not not anytime
soon and when you think about the
partisan divide do you think it's the
fact that republicans were able to win
two recent presidential elections
despite losing the popular vote that
brings them to support the current
system of doing things or do you think
it's more the fact that the electoral
college system is in the constitution
and so conservatives like to be
constitutional originalists so they like
it from that perspective i think it's
very demographically oriented and what i
mean by that is
the older one is the more likely
according to this poll they are to
support the current system and so
republicans skew older and so i'm sure
there's a partisan element to it i'm
sure everything you said is true but
also
there is this age element that i think
is a factor as well what's funny is that
people on the right like to claim that
we should just live in a meritocracy
that we should do away with equity and
we should just count everything equally
they make that argument when it comes to
job applications when it comes to
admissions and universities but for
whatever reason when it comes to the
electoral college they're all they're
all in support of weighing these rural
whiter states more heavily than they are
it's an affirmative action it's an
affirmative action for low population
states that's that's effectively what it
is and listen the meritocracy is
you get more americans to vote for you
you become the president it shouldn't
matter whether
wisconsin versus wyoming versus florida
people are voting for you right now a
voter in wyoming has much more power in
terms of their vote than a voter in
california proportionally um that just
doesn't make any sense to me yeah and i
believe that someone who lives in new
york city is just as much of an american
as someone who is a farmer in iowa and
so their votes should count equally and
unfortunately we don't have a system in
place here in the u.s that allows that
there may have been a case to be made
for the electoral college back in the
day because it may have been more
practical back then but now we can
definitely go by popular vote we have
the means to be able to do that uh so it
makes a lot of sense but because it
makes sense that means we're probably
going to have to put it off for another
20 30 years and then maybe eventually
we'll get around to it yeah i i and even
then i don't even know but
so that's the deal folks uh the american
public
wants to decide the presidency in that
way
and it makes perfect sense to me
slightly shorter bonus show for you
today but i do look forward to seeing
everybody back here tomorrow see you
then